My name is David Robinson. I'm the council member who's chairing
this meeting. It's a Budget and Fiscal Affairs committee meeting. It is Thursday,
May 19, 2022, and it
is just past 09:00. A.m. Nine three and I call this meeting
to order and would like to welcome all council members and staff
who are here in attendance, and we will recognize
them very shortly. But first, I wanted to mention that this budget
workshop procedures will follow.
All budget workshops will be conducted in person, and our
public speakers have the option to comment in person or virtually 48
hours prior to the start of a workshop. All presentation materials
are uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies delivered to each
council office. All departments have been directed to provide
written responses within 48 hours of the conclusion of their
presentation to any questions posted by council members to
SharePoint the budget workshop schedule
is posted on the BFA website. Questions from council
members can be uploaded at any time during the budget workshop
process, the earlier the better, but allowing all the departments
plenty of time to respond to those questions.
All public speakers should be signed in to speak. If you
have not signed up, please sign in at the front table.
My staff here today includes staff
from our Mayor Pro TEM with Chief of Staff
Jessica Beamer, as well as Carolina here, who will be
monitoring the Speaker's list for the fiscal year 2023
budget amendment. Their template has been uploaded
and is available for council members on the SharePoint Budget
Workspace. And Mayor Turner has sent out a memo
to all council members and council offices to ensure productive
discussions on the fiscal year 2023 proposed budget
only operation, budget related amendments will be considered.
Policy amendments should not be submitted and will be ruled
out of order. And please see the Mayor's memo for
additional guidelines. Amendments are
due on Wednesday, May 25, at the end of Business.
And today on our agenda, we will hear from
the Controller with a special BFA Trends
report. We'll hear also from the Controller's office.
We'll hear from the Mayor's office, from Legal,
from Planning, from City Council
and our office collectively,
as well as the Administrative and Regulatory Affairs Group
and Municipal courts. Today is our final day of
the budget workshops. And as a reminder,
these virtual meeting rules, the only people attending virtually are
public speakers. We have seven virtual public speakers
signed up for public comment to speak after the Houston
the Municipal Courts presentation, and there are two
in person speakers that will begin after the virtual public
speakers. We'll get to the questions after the presentation and questions from council members
have concluded. Let me take a moment to recognize my colleagues
who are in the chamber. That's Dr. Carolyn Evans Shabbaz
of district D, the district of destination, as well as council member
Amy Peck from district A. We have staff members
represented from District C,
from District G, from district H.
We have representatives from the Vice Mayor Pro Tems office
in District K from District F on the West
Side, as well as the at large positions four and five
and representing the AtLarge Two office.
I too am here and with that Controller, it's great to see
you this morning. Welcome to the Chamber and sir, the floor is yours.
Thank you. Council members and staff, I'm pleased to present the
Trends Report for the fiscal year ending 2023.
At the time of this report, the economy is showing hopeful progress
in the recovery from COVID-19 Pandemic. The infusion
of more than 5 trillion in federal stimulus nationwide has contributed
to the generous robust sales tax receipt seen since the
passage of COVID relief legislation in Houston.
The receipt of more than 1 billion in response and recovery funding has buoyed
the otherwise bleak fiscal outlook seen pre pandemic.
We project the increases seen in several revenue sources,
namely sales tax, to be temporary.
The FY 23 proposed budget uses 160,000,000
in American Rescue Plan funding to address a habitual
budget deficit. This deficit would have required drastic
expenditure reductions citywide absent the receipt of federal recovery
funding. So this structural deficit existed
before COVID and will exist after ARPA funds are expended.
The decisions we make after and during this fiscal year,
while we have the benefit of the federal dollars, will determine the size of that
deficit in the future. The more than 606,000,000
made available through ARPA funding provides the City with a golden
opportunity to make tangible progress towards reducing the
structural deficit. The Controller's Office encourages
the Administration and Council to address the City's long term
financial liabilities with these funds and avoid adding large
recurring expenditures for which city leadership will have little means to pay in
the future. With that, I'm pleased to present the trends report for
FY 23. Next slide.
We'll move on to the next slide. This is
just a graph summary of all the different financials
and on this slide, General Fund revenues. It shows
the Controller's Office General Fund FY 22 projections,
our FY 23 Trends projections and the historical
information back to FY 18. Next slide.
In the General Fund revenues,
the Controller's Office is projecting an increase in our General Fund revenue projection
by 15.8 million, or 0.6
tenths of a percent from our March FY 22 Mofar
projection. The major drivers of our projected increases are property
tax and intergovernmental revenues. This amount includes
the ARPA funds and we've seen strong sales tax
numbers month over month. But we believe this is the temporary
cumulative result of a low interest rate environment,
business continuing to return to post COVID routines,
and lastly, the infusion of more than 5 trillion in federal
stimulus into the national economy. Next slide.
Property tax revenue. The property tax revenue for FY 23 is expected
to be 3.97% higher than FY 22.
This amount could be higher as terse payments have yet to be paid out.
Property tax revenue continues to be an area of interest for our
office as we monitor the effects of Senate Bill Two and Proposition One revenue
cap. The city is still subject to the provisions of Senate Bill Two and
we believe the variable in Prop One's methodology, the Growth
Index, has the potential to trigger SB Two for the first time.
So, as of today, both prop One and SB Two apply to the city.
But Prop One has been far more restrictive over time and that might
change. Next slide the
Taxable Values based on a preliminary expected taxable value
from the three appraisal districts, the Controller's office projects a 9.42%
increase in taxable values. The final
taxable values are subject to change and will be finalized when the certified
roles are provided to the City. Next slide
taxable value by Type residential properties make
up 53.4% of taxable values and commercial properties
make up 43.8%. Collectively,
the two property types make up 97.2% of taxable
values and as you can see, residential and commercial values
last were even in FY 16. Since then
we've seen the disparity between the two widen and we believe this is
a result of the more aggressive appraisal protests by commercial property
owners and also the significant residential development.
Next slide sales
Tax FY 23 sales tax revenue is projected to increase by
4.76% from our forecast FY 22 sales
tax projection. This decrease is an anticipated result
of the effect of federal stimulus tapering off.
Next slide the
Property Tax Rate this chart shows historical property tax rates. The FY
23 rate is the same as the FY 22s rate but will be updated once
the Prop One calculation is finalized and when the appraisal
district certified roles are made available. It is worth
noting that FY 17 was the first year the city had to decrease
its tax rate to maintain compliance with Prop One.
Next slide total
Franchise Revenue total franchise revenue is projected decreased
by 2.2% from FY 22.
Total franchise revenue has been trending down in recent years.
We believe it's a cumulative result of SB 1152
and that's related to the telecom industries statewide
as well as consumers moving away from landlines
and cutting the cord I e. Digital streaming instead of
cable and satellite. Next slide municipal
Court Revenue municipal courts fines and forfeits are expected to decrease
by 6% for FY 23 based on an expected decrease in collections,
moving violations fees and court operations revenue.
We've seen municipal courts continue to trend down over the years and obviously COVID had
a pretty outsized effect on those revenues. Next slide
General Fund Expenditure Budget the FY 23 General
Fund total expenditure budget is expected to increase by 3.8%
over FY 22 projected expenditures. That's an increase
of 101.7 million. The use of
ARPA funds is the equivalent to which use of non recurring
revenue source that adds pressure to the city's structurally imbalanced budget.
ARPA funds must be leveraged to address the city's structural
deficit and some of its long term liabilities.
Instead, we're adding recurring costs for which we
don't have recurring revenue to match beyond and into
the future. So these recurring costs will exacerbate
an already stressed, structurally imbalanced budget.
Next slide. Here you can just see the general
fund by percentage and function.
Public safety, as you all know, is a lion's share of the budget
as a percentage. And you can see the other breakdowns.
Next slide. The cash
versus fund balance. The unassigned fund balance is
expected to increase by 18.8 million in FY 22
and decrease by 58.8 million in FY 23.
And the projected unassigned fund balance for fiscal
year 2022 is 300 million and for 2023
is 241,000,000. Next slide,
the seven and a half percent fund balance requirement. The FY
projected ending fund balance is expected to be 68 million above the
required seven and a half percent less debt service and PAYGO.
This represents a fund balance of 10.4% above the
required seven and a half percent. This is primarily
a result of the one time financing sources offered through American
Rescue Plan and the 606,000,000 in funding.
But the good news is we do have a pretty substantial fund balance at
this point in time. Moving on,
page 16. Next slide houston
Airport system has
revenue was significantly impacted by the Pandemic,
but our projections for FY 23 demonstrate a rebound as more people begin
to travel by air again, as borders open and foreign
countries relax COVID regulations, we'll continue to see more international
routes come back online. We have yet to see international passenger
numbers return to pre Pandemic levels and ARPA
funds are considered grant dollars and are not included in these
revenue projections.
Next slide,
aviation revenues. The COVID-19 impact on airline travel has resulted
in 370,000,000,000 lost in airline revenue worldwide
and at one point air traffic was down nearly 70%.
So you can see the impact that it's had. But again,
things are starting to rebound with the exception of the international
and some of the business travel. Next slide.
Aviation expenses. Expenditures are up primarily due to personnel
expenditures increasing by 6.3 million or 5.5%
from FY 22. I would caution
Council on this that we need to be vigilant about this very
item expenditures in his going forward,
especially if we do not see that air traffic,
both business and international travel, returning to pre Pandemic
levels and again continue at a growth rate that's
consistent historically. Other services and charges are up
by 4% due to contractual services and interfund police and
fire services. Next slide convention
entertainment revenue and expenses. We anticipate CNE
will continue to see an upward trend in the recovery from the Pandemic.
In FY 23, revenues are expected to increase
by 20.6% or 17.4 million, for a
total of 102,000,000. Expenditures are
expected to increase by 18.6%, or 17.5 million,
for a total of 111.9 million. The FY
23 deficit of 9.9 million ultimately will result in
a decrease in the ending total net position, so they will draw that from fund
balance. But the hope is that in the future things continue.
I know Council member, you've been involved there and seen the
struggle that they've been dealing with, but we're hopeful that things return and they
can build up fund balance in the future with future revenue.
Next slide convention and entertainment revenues.
As you know, CNE was significantly impacted.
Large gatherings and events were canceled due to COVID.
So the primary CNE revenue is hotel
occupancy tax, which is reported as non operating revenue.
Hotel tax collections are projected to increase by 15.8
million, or 20.5% when compared to FY 22,
and this shows that travelers are largely returning to pre
pandemic routines. CNE is also seeing a projected
increase in operating revenues by 22.5%, or 1.7
million. That's due to increases in parking revenue as
a result of downtown area workers and commuters returning to pre pandemic
routines. Next slide,
CNE expenses. The CNE is projecting an increase of
18.6 or 17.5 million in expenses when compared to
FY 22. This increase is primarily a result
of increased debt service payments, an increase in transfer to component
units, namely a transfer of 10 million to Houston first to address
their deficit. Next slide
the combined utility System Revenue and expenses.
US expenditures are projected to exceed revenues by 50.2
million in FY 23, and that's primarily as a result of increased
investment in sewer and wastewater systems. And that's what's
legally obligated as part of the EPA's consent decree.
As you recall, this agreement Stipulates 2 billion investment must be made in
the next ten years. Our office is noting an increase in personnel
cost, salary cost, as well as nearly 1.2 in performance
based bonus for FY 23. So again,
as we continue to see this recovery, we need to make sure, not just
in our general fund, but also in our enterprise funds, that we are managing
our expenses. Next slide
combined Utility System Revenue The C US total revenue is
expected to increase by 92.6 million, primarily due to increased
water and sewer sales. However, these increases are
offset by decreases in projected sales of scraps and other revenue and impact
fees. Next Slide c
us expenditures. C US total expenditures
are expected to increase by 328.1 million and
that's due to debt transfer to capital projects and
maintenance costs. Changes in operating and maintenance expenses
reflect increases in personnel expenses, largely due to
pay for the increase in FTE headcount by 123
in FY 23.
Next slide.
I think that's the end of the presentation, so happy to answer
any questions. Thank you very much, Controller. I appreciate that and
a number of very helpful observations. And while
I might have a question or two, I wonder if there are any
from the array of council members assembled,
we do have four virtual we
think there are two virtual public attendees online,
and we may start with those.
But before going to that, I want to point out that
your points about the airport system and Houston first are
particularly helpful, I think today for some of those extracurricular
things that we really haven't seen too much of here. We did have a good
report from the director of the airport system yesterday with
his budget and there was some narrative and discussion
about the surrounding overall capital
campaigns investment that they're putting into the new facility.
So appreciate your reminders on that. So with that,
I believe we will go to the public speakers and we'll call first Miss Saba
Blanding. Ms. Blanding, if you're
there, please unmute by hitting star six.
I think we see. I believe I'm unmuted. Can you all hear me?
Yes. Good morning, Ms. Blanding. Oh, wonderful morning.
How are you all doing today? Doing well, thank you.
And I apologize. I was trying to finish a walk before you got to
us, but you're like on top of it today, so I'm
outside. Yeah, and it's a little hard to hear you, so if
you can speak slowly and clearly,
that would be very helpful.
Absolutely. So I just wanted to take advantage of this new format
and give you all a chance to brag on yourselves and ask what
is the one thing you're most proud of Houston accomplishing in 2021?
And especially for district council members,
I'm just curious, especially for your district, specifically, what you're most
proud of? Well, thank you for that nice
question this morning from the Garden. I think I heard you say. I don't
see any district council members jumping to
respond. I know my big district. It's the at large city.
Very proud of the diversity of our eleven
distinct districts and the incredible nature
of our communities and overlapping neighborhoods.
Just makes me proud to be a part of everything going
on in the city right now. Ms. Planning. How about you? What are you proud
of? Me?
Yeah.
I really appreciated council member Plumber at
her amendment adding the additional two MCOT teams.
So anything we can do to invest in more
preventative direct mental health care is always a win on
my part. And I'm also loving the bike lanes you all are doing
and always the Bayou expansion is amazing.
It's a long list, so those are a top three,
top of mind. Well, very good. Thank you very much for being here today and
for your ongoing attendance here. Our next
speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver joining us
virtually. Mr. Oliver, if you can hit star six or
speak now.
Calling Jason Oliver. If you can unmute
and join us online.
Good morning. Thank you.
I'm thinking about this presentation and I'm wondering,
so the structural deficit is of course, something that comes
up every year. If we get rid of
the revenue cap,
I think that's around 280 or so million.
I'm wondering, will that kind of get us
to a place of being able to
fully fund some of these departments that we see are struggling,
right? If we do, will that address some of the needs that we've seen
over the past few days? And then also in terms
of ARPA funds, where are you seeing some strong opportunities
and candidates for investment that we may or may
not be doing? I'm trying to figure out are we making those structural investments?
Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Oliver, for the question. The controller
may have something he'd like to say. Here he is. Sure. Thank you for the
question. The first part being able
to repeal and again, I believe that would have to
be through a voter referendum, the property revenue
cap, prop One, rev cap that would
go a long way towards eliminating the
structural budget imbalance based on the current numbers.
The challenge is we also have SB Two, the statewide
rollback rate cap that we'd have to contend with.
So it might not be as effective as
possible. But I know that there has been discussion about that.
One of the things that I've suggested in the past, having been
here now for 19 years and remembering Mayor Bill
White, he passed an amendment to lift the revenue cap
for a specific purpose, primarily for public safety.
And he was able to, again, through referendum,
raise a $90 million cap for public safety.
That could possibly be an interim step. And I know the administration has
tossed that around in the past. To the
second question, the structural budget imbalances
existed before this administration, even as far back before the
White administration, during the Brown administration. So the
challenge is it keeps growing every year. And unfortunately,
this particular year, because of all the federal
money, it's going to grow substantially more, and that
is only cumulative into the future. One of
the things I've kind of said ad nauseam is the PFM report that
the administration and council, you know, approved and and
authored back in 2017.
There are, you know, over 50 different items on there.
And one of the things, in talking to the various consultant groups that
we interact with, they said, this is a great
plan, but you need someone to go out and implement it. And specifically in
the consulting world, what they call PMO program management offices.
And it takes dollars to implement a lot of these things.
Well, we have wonderful employees at the city. We've been
stretched thin. People are doing more with less.
So to answer your question, one of my suggestions
would be to take some of these federal dollars, invest them to
implement program management offices, essentially consulting groups
to go in and to implement these PFM
recommendations. Because as you all recall, the cumulative
effect of increased revenue and reduction in expenses
per the report was around $300 million.
So there's, I think, a lot of opportunities to spend this money
in a way that it doesn't create a recurring expenditure
in the future, but spend it to actually reduce those or
create new revenue. Thank you very much,
Controller. I think that's a very helpful response
to Mr. Oliver. Thank you for your question, sir.
And I do see one council member in
the queue just now. Council Member Alcorn. Go ahead. Thank you, Chair. And thank
you, Controller. I'm sorry I walked in a little bit late and maybe you talked
a little bit about since it's a trends report, the trend of
inflation and the trend of higher interest rates. How do you see that
playing out in revenues and expenditures?
So it is a challenge. We are in a very inflationary
period. We are seeing inflation numbers that haven't been
recorded since the 1980s.
It's a challenge for the city in the sense the cost of goods, of everything
we purchase are going up. Really to
add on to that, interest rates are rising. So the cost of debt service and
issuance, so these are putting financial strains on the budget.
The good news right now is we do have a lot of federal money.
Sales taxes up, property taxes up. But one of the things that
I've termed, and I'm going to date myself, when I started working
in an investment bank, alan Greenspan was the Federal Reserve Chair
and towards the end of the.com
boom he coined a term irrational
exuberance because stocks are rising, money was coming in.
I've said I think right now and again, I've been here
19 years, I've been through the.com I'm 30 years almost
in financial markets. It seems to me a
little bit like irrational exuberance. We're seeing sales tax
receipts over 20% on average. I mean, this is great news.
But the key for governments is it has to be sustainable.
And so the combined factor of
increased inflation, increases in interest rates that are going to hit
debt service and then this kind of false sense of security
on revenues. I'm, as I said, more cautionary
going forward. And for this fiscal year things are good
and probably next fiscal year, but when we run out of the federal
ARPA money, when that's limited? In December of
2024. Really what's going to supplant that and
you've talked about it in the past. The key is matching recurring expenditures
with recurring revenues so we can't have a one time financing source
with recurring expenditure. Thank you, council member. And your
response, Controller. Go ahead.
Sure. Just one more question about the recent changes
to the OPEB, to our
retiree benefits which will bring down our long term
liability. Are you still in favor of looking into
an OPEB trust as well?
Yes. And I am. And this is a great example. In one of the things
that's mentioned in the PFM report, if we
set up an OPEB trust, essentially we are able
to not just do PAYGO for these retiree
healthcare benefits, we would actually invest that similar to
the way we do in the pension. We would earn a return on that money.
The challenge in starting the OPEB Trust is that we've never
had the money to be able to fund it initially.
And now we're sitting on this huge amount of federal money.
What we can accomplish by putting 30,
maybe $40 million into seat and OPEB Trust is,
first and foremost, we can secure health care benefits for retirees, because as
you all know around this table, those are not protected by state law.
We could vote as a council body tomorrow and eliminate all of the retiree
health care benefits. But more importantly, we can use a higher
discount rate when we are evaluating that unfunded liability.
So by putting a $30 million seed and starting
an OPEB Trust, we could significantly reduce the
long term unfunded liability of the OPEB,
and we could do similar to what we did with the pensions. We had an
$8 billion unfunded liability and now closer
to 1.5 billion. Even with the reforms that Council passed previously
on OPEB, we're still going to see probably in the next 15 years,
4 billion or three plus billion dollar unfunded
liability. This OPEB Trust spending, that amount of money would go a long
way to reducing that long term unfunded liability.
Thank you, Controller. That'd be a great start. Appreciate the question.
Council Member Alcorn. We're going to hear from staff from Council Member Huffman's office.
Hi, Controller. I have two questions about the PFM report that you brought
up. One, given it happened in 2017, even though
we paid like $500 million for it, do you
think given all those changes since then, those recommendations are still
relevant today, and then two,
in your opinion, could ARPA dollars be not certainly
better spent, but spent on implementing some of those cost
savings that the PFM report recommends? Yeah, so good question.
I think around $580,000 that we spent on
the report. Absolutely.
To the extent the ARPA money is fungible and we can
use some of that for implementing these ideas,
I would think there would probably need to be a refresher
in the sense that yes, it has been five years.
But I think the good news is, based on inflation and some
of these other things, there might actually be more opportunity to save money
today than in the past. But I think
that the challenge is identifying the right teams
to be able to go out and do this, that have experience doing
it in other cities and can do it in a cost effective manner.
Because one of the things I have seen historically
at the city is we've spent money on projects like this and
we spent a lot of money on them, and they haven't utilized the results.
So I think it's important who you'd select. But I think
absolutely, I think that was kind of the point I made earlier.
We need to be using these federal dollars to reduce the
structural imbalance in the future by adding more revenue or reducing recurring
expenditures, rather than adding recurring
expenditures. Thank you for that
response and that gets to the end of our questions
from the Horseshoe. And I just wanted to get
one further bit of commentary from you. You quoted
Greenspan with the irrational exuberance of times past.
And in one of your charts for the sales tax revenue you
spoke about the tapering off effect of some of the stimulus and
curious about that, having heard recently the state's
comptroller, Mr. Hager, talk about where
we are with some of the incredible returns that we were
getting through last year. Just in
your opinion, is that part of the irrational exuberance
or is that what's about to taper off? Well, I think it's
to this point the irrational exuberance I think we're seeing yesterday in the stock market,
for example, we're down 1100 points on the Dow. I mean, I think
inflation, all these things really it's the multi
trillion dollars of money that's been pumped into the economy that's just pushed
everything up. It's pushed the stock market up. The rates of interest
rates being lowered have done that as well. But definitely, I think from
us. I can't remember a time at the city where
we had an eight month rolling average of over 20%
in sales tax. Now you have to couch that historically
because COVID it was down quite a bit. But even with COVID
being down, the rebound is spectacular.
So just a principle
for governmental budgeting. You really just
plan on having a 3% to 5% increase hopefully
every year and you base it off that. And if you go way below that
or you go way above that, that delta starts to get very
difficult to manage. So I think we were down and
now we're so high up, I just caution the body that it's
not going to sustain itself. And yes, we do expect sales tax to
normalize next year and even be down
year over year. But again, that's because we're up probably in the year,
up 20% this year. And these are good things. It's just you have
to prepare when you have very volatile times. You have to make kind
of more long term strategic decisions in the sense that it's not going to
go up another three or 5% probably next year. It's definitely
not going to go up 20% again next year. I appreciate
that very much. Thanks for that final comment. And I think this does conclude
our special called BFA committee meeting. So. Thank you,
Controller.